hey it's justine and this is m keynote
with ijustine made by motionvfx i'm a
video editor i've been editing for i
don't know so long i don't even wanna i
don't wanna date myself i partnered with
motionvfx to work on this really fun
pack called m keynote so if you guys
want to get a chance to check it out
i'll put a link in the comments it's
super easy if you have final cut
premiere or davinci you just drag and
drop these plugins into your timeline
and you're able to customize them the
text the colors the animations almost
everything is customizable i love that
this has so many fun backgrounds to
choose from it has a bunch of info
boards called action buttons like
subscribe follow like learn more there's
charts and more charts line graphs bar
graphs what do you want we've got them
you can animate your logo just by drag
and dropping your logo into the drop
zone and voila magic i really like these
little text clouds these are some of my
favorites these are placeholders and
these are so easy to use again drag and
drop a timeline and then drag and drop
in the footage that you want to be
inside of those placeholders